et on attend avec bruno daroux cette
conférence de presse de catherine
colonna et son homologue ukrainien
dmitro couler bas bonjour brunoh bonjour
je viens donc catherine colonna première
représentante française à se déplacer en
ukraine à kiev depuis le début de la
guerre il était temps oui d'une certaine
manière il était temps en tout cas c'est
certainement comme ça que le personnes
les ukrainiens la guerre a commencé
depuis trois mois et une semaine
beaucoup de dirigeants se sont rendus à
kiev elle est responsable de l'union
européenne au feu la fanb airlines
charles michel notamment des présidents
ou des chefs de gouvernement le
président polonais estoniens lettons
sont allés voir directement le président
zelensky le premier ministre britannique
à voorhees jeune sun a fait le
déplacement la france ne l'avaient pas
fait ni au niveau des manuels macron ni
un niveau inférieur aujourd'hui le stade
symbole important mais c'est un peu un
symbole en demi teinte c'est à dire que
c'est très important que la chef de la
diplomatie se rendent à kiev évidemment
la chef de la diplomatie française en
demi teinte parce que sans doute les
élus les ukrainiens auraient préféré se
soit emmanuel macron alors il est pas
seul dans ce cas le président byden ne
s'est pas rendu lui-même sur place le
chancelier olaf scholz ne l'a pas fait
non plus donc bon il ya des raisons de
sécurité effectivement mais pour les
ukrainiens le fait que les deux pays les
plus puissants de l'union européenne la
france et l'allemagne n'est pas envoyé
leurs dirigeants à kiev ça à l'aise
quand même un petit goût un petit goût
amer à shred évoqué les tensions entre
kiev et paris est ce que cette visite
peut les apaiser écoutez il faut
l'espérer il ya eu alors détention au
mois parfois des malentendus puisque le
lien a été maintenue quand même un lien
téléphonique assez réguliers entre le
président maquereau et le président
zelensky bon il ya un premier malentendu
sur le positionnement qu'il faut avoir
avec moscou les deux ne pariez kiev ne
se comprennent pas toujours très bien
kiev 10 en gros
vous vous maintenez un canal de
communication avec la russie pour quoi
faire vous semblez crédibiliser vladimir
poutine dans cette période
il accuse à demi mot la france mais
aussi l'italie de préparer un plan de
paix une sortie politique
qui inclurait des concessions
territoriales de la part de l'ukraine ce
qui est inacceptable et côté paris on
dit bon à kiev c'est un peu le tout ou
rien certes parfois c'est qu'on va
reprendre toute l'ukraine pas question
de négocier claude cauxois etc les
russes et puis parfois c'est bon alors
maintenant il faut vraiment un entretien
direct entre poutine et zelensky on a un
peu de mal à suivre donc il ya ya ya
quand même ce ce malentendu après et les
dossiers sur lesquels les deux pays ne
coopère bien d'ailleurs catherine
colonna l'a rappelé sur le le dossier
par exemple des enquêtes concernant les
exactions commises à butch à la france a
déjà envoyé des gendarmes à elle le fait
très tôt alors envoyé une deuxième
équipe donc là-dessus la france on est
très solidaire pour essayer de d'établir
la vérité bon il ya toujours une
prudence de la france qui veut pas
pointé du doigt vraiment la
responsabilité russe dans ces exactions
vous avez entendu bon c'est la chef de
la diplomatie mais c'était extrêmement
prudent a même pas de désignation de le
ton était très différent avec jean yves
le drian oui voilà là on est quand même
voilà on est dans un dans un registre
beaucoup plus prudent
bon il ya évidemment ça va être un des
gros points discussions aujourd'hui à
kiev et à bruxelles le blocage des dans
les ports ukrainiens des millions de
tonnes de céréales et d'oléagineux ya
sans doute les ukrainiens qui veulent
avoir des éclaircissements sur le
concept macro nhien une communauté
politique européenne qui serait si on
comprend bien une forme de sas de
transition en attendant que l'union
européenne examine la candidature de
l'ukraine ça prend des années les
ukrainiens voudraient que leur
candidature aille plus vite mais paris
et berlin là encore leur dise on peut
pas faire ça pour vous parce qu'il ya
six états des balkans occidentaux qui
attendent parfois depuis 16 ans
dans un cas 14 ans dans l'autre femme on
doit respecter c'est très long mais
parce qu'il faut respecter tous les
chapitres
l'adhésion à toutes les valeurs de
l'union européenne ça prend du tombereau
peut dire ça prend beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de temps donc voilà cette
communauté politique européenne karl en
est le contenu exact peut-être que
catherine colonna apportera des réponses
à son homologue ukrainien